Michael Scott thank you I appreciate it
Mike all right oh I don't believe we've
been introduced
Dwight Schrute assistant regional
manager Andy Bernard regional director
in charge of sales so you'll be
reporting to me then on the contrary my
title has manager in it and I'm a
director which on a film set is the
highest title there is do you know
anything about a poem I know everything
about film I've seen over 240 of them
congratulations
[Music]
hey buddy anything new to report do you
mean to me from you cuz that's how it
works
sure thing buddy am i trying to get
under his skin yes because the angrier
he gets the more marginalized he becomes
meanwhile Andy Bernard is out there lay
it on the charm
hey Angela check this out
it's my new screensaver oh do you like
it I do like it actually thank you you
have such a pretty smile by the way
thank you you're welcome
that was my advice remember I'm the one
who suggested that you fire him probably
the best advice you ever gave me Dwight
and what advice has any given to you
today that you have acted on would none
be an accurate estimate none advice Andy
Dwight may have won the battle but I
will win the next battle mm may have
your attention please
so we'll only take a moment of your time
although I love this company more than
almost anything in the world I have
decided to step down from my post and
spend more time with my family I do not
fear the unknown I will meet my new
challenges head on and I will succeed
and I will laugh in the faces of those
who doubt me it's been a pleasure
working with some of you and I will not
forget those of you soon but remember
well today it is me we all shall fall
in other words I'm quitting so
oompa-loompa do party Dawson Dwight is
now gone which is totally awesome
why was he gone he was such a nice guy
no he was not he was a total douche boo
buddy
doom good morning Pam Oh welcome back
Andy drew I'm drew now Oh drew sorry
apology not accepted because it wasn't
even necessary in the first place
several weeks ago Andy Bernard had an
incident but after five weeks in anger
management I'm back and I've got a new
attitude and a new name and a bunch of
new techniques for dealing with the
grumpies morning Jim hey Andy how are
you good
drew what's that you can call me drew no
I'm not gonna call you that
cool I can't control what you do I can
only control what I do and hey Dwight
how's it going man yes I have decided to
shun Andy Bernard for the next three
years which I am looking forward to it's
an Amish technique it's like slapping
someone with silence I was shunned from
the age of four into my sixth birthday
for not saving the excess oil from a can
of tuna Jim could you please inform Andy
Bernard that he is being shunned Andy
the white says welcome back and he could
use a hug okay tell him that that's not
true Dwight says that he actually
doesn't know one single fact about bear
attacks okay no Jim yeah tell him bears
can climb faster than they can run Jim
tell him and he that's too far
damn you I'm temporarily lifting the
shun thank you means nothing I need you
to do something for me anything okay
calm down I need you to acquire an
inflatable house and/or castle you in a
moon bounce what do you think you've got
an hour i manatee petty cash shunning
resumed do you do you want a drawbridge
unshin yeah that sounds good
Rashad Dwight
Andy it's over oh good she broke up with
you no it's over between you two
ah no way I am NOT giving up you have to
know I don't she doesn't love you she's
marrying me well I don't know about that
because she certainly seems to enjoy
making lovemaking with me Angela Bernard
will never be her name will be her name
you will have to call her that I don't
think so
hey guys why don't we just cool off a
bit
I'm telling you to back down and I'm
telling you that I will never back down
that'll make you oh really
how are you gonna do that through the
use of force that is very general and
does not scare me in the slightest I
will fight you nope okay fine
good a duel the winner gets Angela bye
bye this is nuts
what is your weapon okay you know what
that's enough because this is none of
your business
hey it is my business what happens at
work guess what not happening at work
yes we're gonna do it outside outside of
water Europe is none of your business
then good
so what weapon my bare hands that a
stupid I will use a sword and I will cut
off your bare hands then I'll get
something - I've had two men fight over
me before usually it's over which one
gets to hold the camcorder Angela you
have to put a stop to this right now
I will respect the results of the duel
of course you will I call loser I will
be taking my break at 4 o'clock in the
parking lot I will also be taking my
break at the exact same time and in the
same location what a coincidence
so I either get more involved or I take
a sick day leaving Dwight in charge
on the desk of Andrew Bernard note
pathetic dear Dwight I now you have
received my note how are you I am well
you are no doubt wondering why I have
left this note has come to my attention
that in any physical match with you I
would surely be bested true the soft
underbelly of my refined upbringing is
my soft underbelly there's Andy he's in
his car you guys what is he doing
why isn't white turning around the Prius
is silent if he keeps that under five
miles per hour he deserves the win oh my
god what's happening
Andy's running over Dwight with his car
you give up never get on a face me like
a man
I have a man I'm a bigger man than
you'll ever be I would never sleep with
another man's fiancee you're not a man
you don't know how to take care of her
all you do is dress fancy and see what
does that mean
you can't even protect her protect her
for what bears you idiot with the last
time you saw damn bear in Scranton last
year idiot boy are your legs broken no
my right ones falling asleep a little
bit handy you all right go away - now
I'm winning this yeah back off this
isn't your fight Oh how much is this
gonna cost
Oh what trust fund will take care of
that what did you say I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you I see what you're like
a pig you're like a sasquatch
sasquatches are the strongest animal on
the planet
we'll find call me a sasquatch I don't
get it how could she be sleeping with
you this whole time holy sleep with me
twice what what she's sleeping with you
who they would say she said she was only
sleeping with me
you